ich bin jetzt gerade sogar unsicher ob
ich denn nicht einfach sagen könnte
wollt ihr mich verarschen
ich habe absolut nicht das produkt
bekommen was da abgebildet ist das eben
ganz klare untertitel
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe ich dass ich es mein
dornröschen
ich frage mich gerade ob es bayrische
auf deutsch gibt oder irgendwas zuerst
also leider kann man da keine downloads
kaufen man kann aber so donath maker
kaufen und donnert sorgte ich gehe
einfach mal kurz tricks einmal gucken ob
man ja okay das hat mich jetzt auch
extrem gewundert nur trotzdem bin ich
jetzt gerade sehr überrascht was hier
kommt die akten erster stelle ich mein
ich hab nix eingegeben und hier haben
wir eine menge apple airport natürlich
werden sie jetzt hier nicht unter dem
namen airports verkauft sondern was auch
immer aber ich halte mich gerade warum
sowas kommt wenn man tricks eingibt dann
kommen was anderes naja egal jetzt habe
ich schon verraten worum es geht habt
ihr wahrscheinlich auch titel schon
gelesen und zwar bin ich ja in letzter
zeit immer gerne an bestellen hab es
jetzt schon eine drohne eine kamera eine
überwachungskamera alle möglichen cremes
von bush getestet und ich habe noch ein
weiteres paket und ich hoffe hier sind
die apple apple airports drin also sind
natürlich völlig airports ich habe mir
auch hier die originalen besorgt also
das sind originale apple airports von
heute checken einfach mal ab was diese
airports köln ich habe eben gesehen der
youtuber tubau hat auch schon mal ein
video zu diesen airports gemacht könnt
ihr euch auch sehr gerne anschauen habe
ich in der video beschreibung verlinkt
trotzdem habe ich mir gedacht komm du
machst es einfach auch weil wir sogar
auf einen starken unterschied haben bei
ihm das video dort hat der airports für
12 euro unglaublich gekauft und 12 bis
14 euro und bei mir habe ich dir jetzt
irgendwie sogar für fünf euro gekauft
also ist es echt sehr günstig ich bin
gespannt was ich können will gar nicht
angelaufen schreibt ihr mir gerne mal in
die kommentare was soll ich noch bei uns
bestellen und testen also irgendwelchen
elektro scheiße und dann machen wir es
ja leute hier sind die hab ich bestellt
bluetooth wireless headset stereo
blablabla inhalt von der verpackung
hier ja also das sieht eigentlich eins
zu eins aus wie die echten zumindest das
was einem hier gezeigt wird vielleicht
sind das auch echte und die haben
einfach mit echten geworben kann ja sein
haben sechs euro gekostet runtergesetzt
von 32 euro wir haben 500 drei
bewertungen wie immer natürlich nur die
fünf sterne bewertungen hier an erster
stelle sehr schnell angekommen und das
richtig geil für den preis funktioniert
einwandfrei paris etwas tricky geht aber
great for the price and very first
delivery also gleiches thema wie mit der
sabine im letzten video die ja auf diese
kamera gestellt hat weil sie das nicht
gesehen habt sabine hat sich den
camcorder bestellt und war wirklich
begeistert ich konnte dann am ende
eigentlich nur mit dem kopf schütteln
weil wasser biene an diesem camcorder
toll findet das habe ich bis heute nicht
verstanden
naja vielleicht hat jahns urlaub
wirklich recht und die taugen was das
problem wir jetzt mal ausgepackt
das ganze aus matchball so also wir
machen das ganze mal vorsichtig auf
leute so sieht die verpackung aus
7 s plus die gibt es wurde auch noch in
anderen farben ich habe jetzt natürlich
in weiß genommen hier stehen sie direkt
zum bode drauf hast die alles können ich
denke mal das steht für aufladen
telefonieren musik hören mikrofon und
keine ahnung die sprache ist komplett
auf englisch anscheinend für mich
eigentlich ganz gut wir machen jetzt mal
auf so soll jetzt anders
ja also hier haben wir erstmal das
produkt was mir sofort auffällt wenn man
sich nochmal das bild anschaut was ich
hier hatte also eigentlich das
produktbild auf dem abgebildet ist was
man kauft dann sieht dass hier schon mal
anders aus so auch hier einmal das
original ist viel kleiner als das ja
keine ahnung ich bin jetzt gerade sogar
unsicher ob ich denn nicht einfach sagen
könnte wollt ihr mich verarschen
ich habe absolut nicht das produkt
bekommen was da abgebildet ist da sind
ganz klare unterschiede wenn dir gerne
in die kommentare schreiben wie es damit
aussieht und wenn ihr euch damit
auskennt aber ich mache mir den stress
natürlich nicht so wie machen die
einfach mal auf 12 also so sieht einer
aus marl im vergleich zu den originalen
das kleine ist das original man kann
sehen der hier ist wirklich viel fetter
ich frage mich gerade ob er überhaupt
immer ein ort passt will was mal
ausgearbeitet
final der passt locker und der hier ja
fast eigentlich sogar auch ist nur
wirklich alter krass vielleicht liegt es
auch daran weil mein linkes ohr kleiner
ist als das rechte was eigentlich nicht
der fall es wird also soviel dazu ich
tue einfach mal beide reihen
ok ich ja gar nicht schlecht bei den
originalen sieht man sogar noch ob die
aufgeladen sind oder nicht dann merkt
man auch dass die qualität eigentlich
viel besser ist bei diesem fakes haben
wir den luxus leider nicht aber ich
würde sagen die werden jetzt erst mal
aufgeladen und dann probieren wir die
maus ab sodass hier ist übrigens die an
knopf drückt man drauf dann bringt das
hier einmal blau und hier oben rot ich
denke mal dass steht dafür dass die
aufgeladen werden müssen
die haben wir auch kein apple anschluss
so wie es auf dem foto er ganz klar zu
erkennen ist gut aber das habe ich auch
nicht erwartet deswegen rate ich jetzt
erstmal kurz bis leicht so leute ich
verbindet jetzt gerade mit meinem handy
den habe ich schon verbunden man drückt
einfach ganz lange hier auf den knopf
dann bringt sie irgendwann blau und rot
abwechselnd der hier angezeigt jetzt
starte ich den auch mal eben hier so
blinkt und will den auch aus jetzt
bleibe ich euch hier schöne screenshot
ein also ich hab die wohl jetzt beide
connect steht auf jeden fall hier so
sind beide verbunden
und jetzt schauen wir mal wie sich das
anhört so leute einige zeit ist jetzt
verstrichen ich habe mich ein bisschen
mit beiden dingen vertraut gemacht diese
hier habe ich auch selber noch nicht so
wie ich auch benutzt wir sind folgende
dinge aufgefallen
hier kann man jetzt zum beispiel einmal
direkt sehen sowie prozent ist einmal
diese ladebox gelagert prozent sind die
einzelnen airports geladen das geht halt
bei dem fake dinger nicht aber ist ja
klar ich meine die sind von apple
die sind apple kompatibel und kann man
ohne probleme direkt anschließen also
wenn man die hier öffnet und bluetooth
an hat kriegt man sofort eine
benachrichtigung dass irgendwo in der
umgebung airports sind auf jeden fall
schließt man die beide einfach im blut
schluss an und kann dann jetzt musik
haben und da kann jetzt wieder jede
sabine her kommen und sagen was sie will
aber die qualität also das kann man sich
echt nicht geben so also was anderes
kann ich dazu nicht sagen
stellt euch das auch keinen fall ich
halte ihn gern mal hier dran auf volle
lautstärke
ich glaube man kann ich das jetzt gar
nicht wirklich rüberbringen wie schlimm
das eigentlich ist aber es hört sich
einfach nur noch plastik an die etwas
ruhigeren töne sind auch okay aber
solange ist dann lauter wird solange
lied der refrain ist also da hat das
doch immer so und das ist absolut
unangenehm was mir noch aufgefallen ist
wenn man ein youtube-video hiermit guckt
dann ist das total versetzt also das
kommt nicht passend an
da kommt man durcheinander ist auch so
ein negativer aspekt muss ich sagen da
sind die beiden in meinem buch ist
absolut durchgefallen das einzige was
ich bis jetzt wirklich gefeiert habe
weil hier die überwachungskamera die kam
im letzten video tour falls ihr das noch
nicht gesehen habt schaut euch das gerne
an ist jetzt verlinkt ansonsten würde
ich sagen ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
gibt noch nach oben schreibt in die
kommentare was sie noch testen sollen
und dann machen wir das in den nächsten
wochen genau abonnieren ich vergessen
für weitere videos
haut rein das war es von mir danke fürs
zuschauen